cost me a billion dollars a year to not
know what to do to make a billion
dollars or I do know how to make a
billion dollars and I just have to wait
and pay down my time debt which is what
I feel like I'm doing right now just
paying down time and so I think
understanding whether it's a lack of
knowledge or it's just a timeline thing
like those are big differences you know
I mean at the Baseline right you could
be doing the right thing but just be 10
years behind when it's going to come to
fruition you will get outsized Returns
on the information right on the
knowledge and the lessons that you will
learn and so you want to pay that
ignorance down as fast as you can
because as soon as you have that
knowledge you'll be able to Skyrocket
straight to 20 50 100 500 000 a month
like very quickly because you know how
to do it it's a whole S P 500 versus SME
500 but like you will get a
significantly higher return investing in
your own ability to make money than you
will in any market and so if you look at
the vast majority of very very wealthy
people they have tremendous earning
capacity they know how to do stuff that
makes money we gotta go get that